who should replace Daniel Craig as James
Bond one creative fan is a pretty good
idea fun art depicting Henry Cavill as a
super spy a surfaced online and it's
good enough that if Hollywood execs
haven't considered a casting cavil in
the role before they're probably mulling
it over now the image comes to us
courtesy of digital artist Jacob Mislav
ski Vera's Instagram accounts it's
stylish as all get-out a mouse but
cosmos Lao ski used his top-notch photo
editing skills to alter a photo for a
2015 action-adventure spy film The Man
From UNCLE in which cavil starred as a
charming secret agent Napoleon solo
Mislav ski was evidently inspired by a
yet unconfirmed rumor that surfaced in
September of last year that claimed
Kabul was being I to replace Craig after
next year's forthcoming as yet entitled
Bond film for that matter most Lasky is
the first for this idea
follow photoshop wizard boss logic also
took a crack at kapil as bummed surely
before the rumour started making the
rounds both fun edits definitely have us
hoping that cavil being up for the part
is more than just a rumor the actor is
of course the best known for portraying
Superman in recent DC movies he held
down the role in 2013's Man of Steel
2016's Batman vs Superman thought of
Justice and 2017 s Justice League after
that team-up film fell far short of box
office expectations studio Warner
Brothers was forced to radically rethink
its approach to his DC properties rather
than continue building a singular
interconnected world like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Warner and teens he
went back to the drawing board with a
more filmmaker driven approach focusing
more heavily on standalone films so far
the results have paid dividends this
year Shazam which largely paid lip
service to the established continuity
score with critics and was a modest box
office hit meanwhile the upcoming
joaquin phoenix star a joker is already
garnering early Oscar buzz but it's as a
result of the recalibration characters
that were less warmly received by
audiences like cavil Superman was sent
back to the drawing board for cavil this
means that he should have some time on
his hands if he wants to jump into yet
another iconic franchise of course it's
not like the star is just sitting around
waiting for the phone to ring he'll be
holding down the lead of Geraldton
Netflix his upcoming highly anticipated
live-action adaptation of The Witcher
he's also attached the star of Sherlock
Holmes and Enola Holmes which will see
stranger things Millie Bobby Brown
appearing as a titular younger sister
after
legendary detective but few actors would
sneeze at the opportunity to play
double-oh-seven
and if the stars line up Bryce the 36
year old Englishman could potentially
hold down the road of double-oh-seven
for years to come
just as Daniel Craig has the planned
Britt has made a fine bond admirably
filling the super spy shoes in four
films before agreeing to come back for
one more round and the physically taxing
role the upcoming Bond movie has had its
share of bumps on the road on the way to
screens but sneak peeks released by
director Carrie Jodie Fukunaga promises
a rollicking globe-trotting send-off for
Craig it's doubtful that will get any
official bond casting news until after
the final Daniel Craig Bond flick is
released on April 8 2020 but until then
if this image should help to give fans
executives and casting directors some
serious food for thoughts cavil is a
gifted actor he certainly looks
surpassed and he's British to boot Thank
You mr. mouseling ski for creatively
stating the obvious this man needs to be
the next double-oh-seven
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]